I come in today with my mindset all I'm
doing one thing and now it's complete
180 we're doing something else not only
are we doing something completely
different we have to do it in a really
really short amount of time it needs to
be cool we need to be special
Jake pitched all the ball on this shadow
idea which I don't think he really had
an idea we're shooting on Wednesday
which is two days from now in like a day
or two for shooting day is you have
editing and then a week of effects and
we chose an effects-heavy video would
you be shooting this no but I have three
videos to make hey so who would shoot it
I'll sleep there but this really says
the Mavericks on the side film with the
sword is no chance - fine
I see nope it is the wave - why I wonder
why everybody turns life so true
celebrity is not flown chevy can't be
SMED if you play well for me you gauge
the Bonita
wuzza wuzz affections that piece is a
moment of coolness a little
self-contained spectacle that that are
basically basically it's a natural fax
cross-compile 52 times 12 last year
I blocked almost 2,000 phone numbers
from my phone I get about five six phone
calls a day from telemarketers every
time they call I don't answer and then I
blocked the phone number instantly the
next day I get another four to five
phone calls from telemarketers from a
whole new set of phone numbers that I
have to do it again then the next day
and the next the only day they do not
call this Sunday always after 9:00 and
before 10 p.m. it's really annoying
because I have a Fitbit and my arm will
justify rate every time telemarketers
call has been going on since last
January of 2016 I may have a solution
permanently get all the telemarketers to
stop calling me
we have a brand integration for audible
you guys have seen a couple of olive oil
integrations in the femme Neko channel
which Ryan is graciously recommended
some good books to guys I love books
that's great but this time they've
actually agreed to do a integration on
the corridor channel the downside is we
have to turn around a video idea really
quickly because they want the
integration to come out by April 30th so
we got a write an idea and get it made
and get it out there before the deadline
hits otherwise we lose the integration
except you guys gonna be at any be porch
flight fest and you haven't made a video
before a maybe Jake pitch audible on
this shadow idea which I don't even
really had an idea I think you're just
like shadows what is this is a spiritual
successor to brush with death to paper
cuts it's like there's a very cool like
just perspective scene to it right the
idea projection we spent like two weeks
last year working on some sort of shadow
video just like this and it went nowhere
so we're revisiting it again this year
yeah we need an outline but in the day
I would say it'd be up to you to direct
the piece in terms of like everything
leading up to when shadows start to play
really just focusing on the mood the
setups payoffs and then I left red
handle the visuals so I'm thinking that
we do something waste here here it's do
guys like the break rooms with Proctor
it kind of split up so I guess one guy
sees there's like a line on this
creature that's also a shadow leans out
of the darkness encroaches on this
shadow creature if it if it grabs the
sky it affects them in real life so like
maybe it reaches out and grabs backpack
and so you can realize that if this
shadow creature touches your shadow it
affects you for real like the shadow of
this tree like a shadow and then realize
it's like I stabbed through yeah and
then realize like you see the guy like
blackness appears as jesuits I'm like
sucked into him and yes it's like what
if it starts in black but then slowly
becomes transparent but because the
background is also kind of dark and
black stubble field transparent right
away into like completely gone you
realize you're just staring at nothing
yeah now there's something stages we
know that if you get hit by the shadow
creature you get turned into a shot so
now his friend comes into the room I'm
going to register my cell phone on the
Do Not Call Registry from the FTC it's
the grumpy people lives go to do not
call dot gov do not call her Street does
not expire but what I was googling is
that it takes about thirty one day to in
that even if I do this I still have to
block one hundred and sixty two phone
calls
by the end of this month you lovin those
tips just confirmed
let's you Perry you literally have soft
ones who you want
do these looking really hot like spicy
hot it's the Brielle dude got it keep an
eye out they just shut down like once
you start eating these things you just
have you can't stop because your body
will just shut down like it just quickly
start sweating it's like roof don't go
drink oh no you guys like a 2x4 and I
set it up project a wall so he can't get
through the wall light switch on the
other side of the room it's always cold
the things that the characters on the
screen worry about or the audience don't
care and all the lights are on ceiling
after Kings that he can turn on that
light switch he'll turn on all the
lights of the room thereby destroying
the shadows so he needs to get to that
light switch strips on the cord that has
one light that's still on in the whole
room falls in the darkness and he's like
oh [ __ ] now it's completely surrounded
by shadow and like you film like a dude
on a black background which is like
reaching like it should be later like I
need to be in closer and closer if I can
actually see like the black hands like
the darkest hour of the character yeah
dark it's not exactly I do like this
idea it's just a mistakes beginning cool
visuals that probably won't actually
that hard to do if I do it well it's
kind of darkest hour where things get
the worse they could possibly be and
they get solved right afterwards much
bigger problem at the end who you can't
have played the commute yesterday right
that's a great screen callbacks gate
then
it gives us this week to shoot it and
edit it and next week to do a BEC sound
and music so is there like pilfering
right
you started to listen to the 80 cents
from some reddit dark electronics
expense well I don't give as many calls
as Carmichael does but if I don't know
the number I just let it go I hate that
I'm freelancer in production
it could be someone calling asking me to
gap or crew or whatever so hopefully I
just trust them they're going to leave a
message and I can immediately call them
back and still get the job versus missed
the call not get the thing and then not
get the job because they call someone
registering right now
yeah and I got computer problems but
whatever we gotta come up with an
overarching idea it's got to actually
write it three parties appears now it's
account specifics to lay out exactly
what happens I I treated a few days ago
but it's like literally the hardest
thing I find to do here at work is
literally just coming up with videos
fringe that's like big ideas guy I mean
yeah yeah we're like sure what that is I
consider coming up with a good idea
worth doing is way more difficult than
any of the visual effects the production
side those are all technically hard this
is very implicitly hard you know there's
like there's no way there's no tangible
way to measure a good idea until it's
like done and uploaded you know examine
overall concept that's cool dibban you
did I what's my idea for this line of
dialogue what's my idea for how I
stepped into this team how much tension
do I want for this moment yeah I just
kind of fall back to how you know
structure seeing knows our goal here is
to get a cool script completely done
today or probably get revised a little
bit tomorrow and a project revise a bit
most shooting the biggest problem I see
is that and get turned on so fast and I
won't be here that's going to make being
really on new and Jake to have the mood
and the flow figured out in the minds
and you gets the turn on super fast need
to make sure that it's sufficiently shot
and efficiently edited and that all the
boots ever recovered I hope that goes
smoothly hopefully we don't miss this
integration opportunity that's budget
that actually covers next videos we make
for the next month so yeah I have to
think through the haze of lack of food
the next step in our pre-production day
is to just continue that's the part will
be unless you get back and finish the
day doing these previous steps and
hopefully we'll be prepared for smile
[Applause]
you